Once upon a time, Edward was born the son of the King of Wales.
My son, Prince Edward, will be the King of Wales.
On the same day, Tom was born the son of the beggar Canty.
Oh no, another baby who wants food! Stop crying!
Prince Edward grew up with a good background.
How was school, my son?
Tom had to beg for the money every day, but he liked to read books.
What are you doing here?
Get more money or I'll beat you.
One day, while Tom was begging around the town, he saw a magnificent building in the strange area.
Wow! How beautiful!
Hey you! Get away from the king's gate!
I'm sorry, I didn't know.
When the guard tried to kick Tom out of the gate, Edward saw them.
Guard, let go of him now! How dare you treat someone like that?
Thank you, sir.
You look so hungry. Come with me into the castle for some food.
They ate and talked for a long time in the castle.
Everything is so complicated here.
What's happening outside the castle?
I want to get out of here.
I only wish I could have clothes as nice as yours.
Um, how about trading clothes with each other?
Wow, I can't believe it! You look just like me!
It's amazing.
We're the same size!
Our hair is even the same.
I'll test the guard. It'll be interesting, won't it?
Soon, Edward went to the guard.
The guard thought he was the beggar.
You filthy beggar! What are you doing in the castle? Get out of here!
Get your hands off me. I am your master, the Prince of Wales.
The guard didn't listen to Edward and kicked him out of the castle.
Huh? I just intended it as a joke.
Edward just walked along the street for a long time.
Where should I go? I don't know where I am.